let's get to as we often do on fridays
some stories um that i just sort of ran
out of time for during the week i want
to talk about republican senator cynthia
lummus who represents uh wyoming senator
cynthia lummus spoke the other day at
the commencement of university of
wyoming she gave the graduation speech
and during the graduation speech for
some reason i don't know why
she went in a transphobic direction
injecting into the speech almost like
you would bleach for kovid which is a
bad idea and that was this was also a
bad idea
um the f that people aren't telling the
fundamental truth that there are
only two sexes that anything can be
challenged and in fact what she said was
quite postmodern um in the sense that
she made the claim that now
there's no empirical realities you can
just sort of challenge anything which is
a postmodern idea at its core so let's
look at the clip and then we'll discuss
now she she criticized that i want to be
clear
she didn't make the postmodern argument
she made the argument that sex has
become almost postmodern in that any
opinion about what sex is is equally
valid and whatever okay let's listen
you woke up this morning
with more individual freedom in the most
creative divinely inspired nation on
earth oh and one of the things is the
video is sort of like sped up so i'm
going to turn it down so it's at like
normal speed
the transformations and disruptions i
have alluded to are testing those very
freedoms
beyond watch
there are those in government who
believe
not that the creator endowed us with
inalienable rights as the founders of
our nation acknowledged in the
declaration of independence
so by the way first of all
suggesting that it sort of should be
like the official thing in the united
states that everything we have all the
rights we have came from god which
remember they they love to do this they
love to say
the creators the framers of the
constitution the founding fathers
they believed that rights came from god
or in religion or whatever the case may
be sure they were deists but they
believed it shouldn't have a role in
civil government they'll they'll skip
that part but let's continue that
government created those rights and the
government should redefine those rights
including our rights to freedom of
speech
religion property assembly and to keep
and bear arms
even fundamental scientific truths such
as the existence of two sexes male and
female are subject to challenge these
days
[Applause]
and they boo
you know i
[Music]
[Applause]
it's not normal for commencement
speakers to be booed
[Applause]
and i challenge those of you
i'm not making a comment on the fact
that there are people who transition
between sexes
so just stepping into it further and
further so there's a couple of different
things here first of all as usual
sex and gender
lummus is quite confused at the same
time it is a scientific truth that some
people are born intersex so
even though of course she's confused
between sex and gender
uh she also states wrongly
that it's a fundamental scientific truth
that there's male and female but in fact
i know it's a small percentage of people
but if if you want to bring up science
you kind of have to acknowledge that
she's also wrong on that but that's not
even really the issue
these commencement speeches the whole
idea is you bring a speaker who ideally
is going to be inspiring to the people
in the audience it is going to sort of
set up you're going to kind of wind them
up and send them off with energy and and
uh hope and ambition
to do things to improve the world
and instead she took the speech as an
opportunity
to do transphobic stuff
to do uh religious stuff as religion
should be part of government
talked about guns you saw her talk about
the second amendment this is just the
complete wrong place for it and
unfortunately the initial response from
the school president was pretty
mealymouth the ed seidel or seidl is the
president of uw and initially put out a
statement saying on saturday the
university celebrated spring
commencement with a series of events
that showcased blah blah blah one of our
speakers made remarks regarding
biological sex that many on campus take
issue with
while we respect the right of all to
express their views from students to
election elected officials we
unequivocally state that uw is an
institution that supports and celebrates
its diverse communities
that collectively make us the wonderful
place that we are
uh we welcome the incredible
individuality and intellect of all of
our dynamic and diverse students and
never want you to feel otherwise so not
really a criticism of the actual speaker
and then that statement after being
decried is not very good another
statement was point put out uh the
following day from the university which
was a little more clear and it said
unfortunately during one of the
ceremonies there was reason for pause
amid the celebration and they name her
they say wyoming senator
cynthia lemus
offered the following statement they
quote the statement about two sexes our
faculty staff and students know that is
not the scientific truth
we affirm that humans may comprise
various chromosomal variations not every
person is strictly born female or male
intersex members of our community who
have diverse chromosomal makeup should
be seen and recognized now
that's also kind of a cop-out
only in the sense that
the reason
the lummis statement confuses sex and
gender anyway because she's confused
and they take the same approach i
initially took which is to say
even assuming she meant sex
she's wrong
really the issue here is a broader issue
about gender and transgender but it
doesn't matter it was good to see that
after being shamed university of wyoming
put out and and listen
you don't always want to attack the
speakers that you invite i get it
uh but they said it and i'm glad to see
it but just what what a dumb speech i
don't know any other way to say it if
you're using traditional toilet paper
and paper towels you're probably cutting
down trees from north american old
growth forest and i've talked about
before we don't want to be doing that
also they come wrapped in single-use
plastic that's also a mess and the
solution is real paper this is a sponsor
i feel great about real paper makes
paper towels and toilet paper from
fast-growing bamboo not from virgin tree
fibers from forests using bamboo
prevents soil erosion it prevents
habitat loss and importantly it's a
major impact on carbon real paper also
uses no plastic packaging so we often
talk about what can we do
corporations need to do many things but
what can we do to help the environment
this is an easy thing and i made the
switch to real paper at home i can't
tell the difference everybody buys
toilet paper everybody buys paper towels
this is one you can actually feel good
about and you can use the code pacman
for 30 off your first shipment when you
sign up for a subscription at
realpaper.com
pacman the link is down below